i've just met this person
i've just come on a seminar i met this
person i don't know how strong he is
but all of a sudden
oh i'm in trouble
all right so so all that
this is what i'm seeing a lot of
what what what's moving because down
there nothing is there but
my body is my body's trying to sort of
like i'll lower myself
all right
little is more
all right if you stick to if you stick
to the program you can't see yourself
and there was a mirror in front of you
and you saw
you saw that you say i need to see
someone and it's not a doctor that fixes
me with medicine it might be medicine a
lot of it
turn
okay so the next way
the next way
is
is your coke you
i'm not just throwing it down
i've got a direction do you know what
the direction is
what we've been doing all day
all right
so
right so what we're going to do next is
i'm going to do
iccio you might have to move a little
bit for this one
if i let go of that and then we go back
here and i do this and i come here
and i come here
these are what i call singular
iccios
all right come up
as long as you've always got something
it's when you let go of everything you
haven't got anything
so what i'm going to do is
say his head's turning the other way
so his head's turning away from me
he's not going to be able to see what i
want you to show this hand now the top
hand is going to be
here
i'm not going to be too close to him
at some point he'll see my hand
so at some point he'll see my hands
all right as long as you've got a little
bit of yonkyo
on here
he doesn't know the young goes until he
goes to move
yeah see being big and strong is not
everything
okay so you can try the fancy bits if
you want why not try them try them this
is it will you know if you're going to
succeed you take them down
you put your hand next to their head
doesn't matter they can't see you but
you'll be following them with your eyes
the minute his eyes do see you
they'll react
back off at that point back off at that
point back off because you've got them
don't be in their face and try pushing
one is they'll never get up
and they'll also build up their
their strength without you knowing it
they'll go oh he's gonna try and
threaten me
so
so if i take him down and i do this and
i keep pushing sees now strong i'm gonna
have a job now
doing the technique
so
about halfway
far too much information isn't there
right about halfway
i'm going to back off